>> Android 2.0 provides new APIs and technologies
for developers. This platform release includes
new capabilities in Accounts Management, Contacts,
and Sync. There is now an Account Manager
API that enables a developer to store centrally
account credential info on the device. The
Contacts Application support syncing and aggregating
contacts data from multiple accounts. And
the Sync Adapters API provides full two-way
contact sync to any backend. Quick Contact
provides users a fast, easy way to communicate
with others. Selecting the picture frame shows
all communicating methods available. In selecting
an icon, here, Gmail, lets users start communicating
right away, but this feature is available
in not just contacts. Note how it’s here
in the messaging application. The Quick Contacts
API lets developers build this feature into
any App. Android 2.0 includes the Bluetooth
API that lets Apps turn on and devises Bluetooth
discover and connect to nearby devices and
send and receive data. Here is a demo game
that takes advantage of the API’s capabilities.
The Bluetooth API now enables Apps to integrate
easily features such as peer-to-peer communication
and proximity-based social interactions. The
platform began supporting devices with different
screen sizes starting with Android 1.6. In
this example, the place is Directory App renders
correctly on three different screens with
a single version of the application. Using
the Android UI toolkit, developers can easily
build a single binary to support devices with
various screen sizes and resolutions. To learn
more about the Android 2.0 release, visit
developer.android.com.